that construction man that [__] should
be illegal in space yeah are you talking
about to the launch the launch pad yeah
yeah yeah they really they really are
[__] with the roads out there it's
annoying they're like the city goes
what would be a good time to start
construction
6 a.m yeah
6 a.m to uh 6 a.m to 6 p.m yeah that'd
be perfect yeah yeah yeah yeah
do people need to drive here 6 a.m to 6
p.m then yeah yeah I love how we're all
like California the taxes are so high
what do they do with the money the roads
all suck and then they try to fix the
roads and we're like the [__] are you
doing let us drive on the roads yeah
well the [__] are my taxes doing I want
to drive on the roads no for what for
those taxes on those uh
Shady construction contracts they're
handing out
that construction should be done in
three days we know how construction goes
at those levels they don't really know
how construction goes at that level they
just drag it out to make it seem like
the time they quoted was correct I mean
they've been doing that they've been
working on that same road yeah the one
you know yeah for like a year now yeah
and I used to love making that turn same
because it takes me my route home was so
sick yeah and now it sucks ass yeah
yeah
now I gotta drive by [__]
uh This is Gonna doxus but Montana's
[__] stupid restaurant are those
Applebee's
Montana's yeah I thought that's what it
was called uh might be the different one
I'm talking about like this Montana
themed I thought it was a chain yeah
everyone uh cut that out both of those
places yeah insert other things chilis
and Applebee's
let's give let's give it clean Chili's
yeah I used to drive by my favorite
restaurant
you ever been to a Montana's no oh never
mind you travel a lot look at this
that's the logo right there is this a
Canadian chain it is
if you're listening Cody's Cody's just
trying to cover up right now he's really
just talking about taking a PJ to
Montana
on vacation I used to live in this place
Montana I'd walk into the airport and
I'd be like uh when's the next one to
Montana and then I just that's my
favorite restaurant yeah
this is the entire state
oh when you land I just see it as a
restaurant because it's just I fly there
just to eat yeah there's so much there's
so many animals out there to kill
everyone that lives in Montana to me is
just a waiter yeah another place called
Jack asters
you ever see that place
pull up Jack Asters Jack asters had a
big donkey logo chat GPT pull up Jack
asters
there it is right there we gotta make
our own chain with a little swear word
in it oh yeah like
oh you have to bleep that because we
can't say it oh I was thinking more
along the lines of like dick [__]
yeah something not smart dick [__]
Bar and Grill yeah ball Slammers Bar and
Grill
it's like Hooters but instead of the
women dressing scantily clad they just
wear steel toe boots and you can get
your nuts kicked at any time
oh that's good actually it's like one of
the places where the they're mean to you
yeah but like physically yeah they
physically assault you yeah yeah so if
you're into that kind of thing yeah
you'd be like can I get some chicken
tenders and some shame
yeah and and if you really want to spice
it up you can sit in the patented dump
hole chair yeah and the dump hole chair
has a hole beneath your nuts yeah so if
you wear soft pants a waitress can walk
by at any time and just Ram her foot
through the bottom of your chair into
your ass into your ass
oh you don't see it coming yeah yeah oh
let me just come ball real quick yeah
I'm dining on the Taco Bell [__] ball
this morning those things are filled
with come
like show that to the camera and squeeze
it a little bit
isn't that incredible
it tastes like Compton
oh
wait you didn't do you like it
thank you
what's wrong
oh no no I just think I should call him
[Laughter]
what a guy hey by the way let's promote
this
oh the fujista freeze yeah the fertisa
freezes
by the way let's promote this Batista
drinks
[__] are these clothes doing here yeah
uh promote this brand new water bottle
that I don't know what it is
great for a fertista freeze yeah
yeah yeah forget I said that yeah that
is a great stupid logo is but then yeah
what's that dumbass logo on this
uh Squad 6A leave it on the gym floor
I'm gonna leave all this for teeth to
freeze on the gym floor can you peel
this off yeah I mean we could just
freeze this in here can we get a knife
so we can scrape off this dumb logo now
this actually is extremely sick we have
brand new merch out today folks yeah it
rules all [__] rules squat 680. well
we call this the squad 680 collection
we could or the spring collection
look at how sick that is the shirts are
so thick
we're using almost like a fruit used to
freeze almost like a fruitista freeze
exactly
uh can we say the blank
would people know them no no I wouldn't
the blanks are fantastic super thick
really high quality
we have this one
equally as sick if you're listening and
you can't see the clothes let me just uh
let me get you go ahead and give you a
little sample here
there you go that's what they sound like
and this hoodie right here
a nice sort of rust color on this one
with just that logo that's that's uh
embroidered too
yeah a real nice merch and then go buy
some I actually love this if you want
I'm gonna use this yeah often yeah I'm
gonna use this right now actually
yep
blue flavor in here
it's our fratista bottle yeah
yeah I'm actually just draining out all
the syrup so I don't actually have to
drink any ice
so you get just walk none of the freeze
only the participate oh [__]
foreign
there you go you don't want to waste
that good for Tista
and also stickers I think I just
I think that was about a week's worth of
sugar
yeah well I mean that plus the gumball
yeah I'm we're in for a rough second
episode yeah
we're gonna be so hyped for the next 30
minutes the diabetes is so Random
spiking yes so random dude we're gonna
be so [__] so hyper yeah we're gonna
be so [__] hyper dude
so random dinosaur
what where'd that come from
I'm so hyper right now
it's really funny thinking about kids
being like
ooh I'm so hyper right now
and those are just all the kids that
couldn't drink their dad's whiskey
other 13 year olds like what are you
doing dude I'm trying to clean it up
generally I'm just patching up all the
ice and [__] the stickers look great on
the bottles oopsie
foreign
I love that feel when you reach inside
your
Fructis to freeze
because you're just so excited you can't
wait to drink it that you just have to
fist you have to yeah yeah yeah we can't
get enough freeze through the straw yeah
so you just hit it like a two like a one
pound tub of cream cheese
yeah some of these this fruitista is
scallion flavored actually yeah
this one's lox flavored
Cody has the Lox flavored fruit juice to
freeze I have this scallion flavored for
Taste of freeze I had locks recently for
the first time in a long time yeah so
good you know
I love it what's so good about locks
uh locks of balls in your mouth yep yep
that's good that actually is a good one
lox Bagels yeah
locks of bagel nuts in your mouth yeah
you [__] with you [__] with lots
I'm surprised no one's used locks
congrats dude you discovered a new one
yeah
wow
just take a minute to honor that let's
go all right I just sorry I need to get
I got to get a sip from by the way where
can they get this tmgstudios.tv perhaps
can we get confirmation on that
that's true yeah you can get all this
merch you get your fruit bottle on
tmgstudios.tv damn so crazy just rolling
to the gym with that yeah
just Mountain Dew nice
you've seen that clip of Tom Segura and
Bert Kreischer of course yeah that's
such a classic it's a Kool-Aid yeah
um I have some clips that I want us to
watch okay I'm down but first of all I
have to ask what are these these aren't
fratista freezes
what are these they're like aren't these
like the Mountain Dew blasts or whatever
yeah the Baja Blast Baja Blast bro is
Baja a Mountain Dew
dog
I'm sad
why
the fruitista freeze it's just such a
it
what can you look at the ingredients I
don't know how you describe it the syrup
they'd use they had way better flavors
pina colada mango yeah that's strawberry
mango
God man yeah it's like lapping
this [__] is All Too Fake like what
flavor is Baja
Prime
what is it
what is Baja Blast
it's just gamer piss gamer piss yeah
dude I want to say the strawberry
component
it's like it's like grenadine or
something lime
tropical okay and then for cheese to
freeze like the strawberry syrup they'd
use it's like something you'd expect
like a Shirley Temple
um are they really were just like
cocktails with no
yeah they were fully mocked I wonder if
there's a secret menu where you could
get it spiked
yeah Taco Bell Cantina oh man you're
awesome the one in Vegas
you ever been to that one
no but you know the one we have into you
know what
the one in Sacramento oh [__] Downtown
Sacramento and San Jose they're nice
they are
just that [__] with like shots of rum in
it oh yeah it's the best